welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you mitzi my my kindred spirits
ah i'm struggling because i'm single in
a pandemic
and it doesn't help that i have trust
issues you know but i'm finally starting
to let my guard down
and this really cute guy dm'd me on
instagram
and we're chatting we're hitting it off
and he's perfect like he eats every part
of the chicken and he respects michelle
branch you know those are two things i
look for in a soulmate
and we're talking for maybe three weeks
four weeks
and this is all still on instagram no
phone numbers so one night i'm feeling
frisky
and i say let's facetime i'm nervous
because we've never had face-to-face
interaction
and i'm waiting for him to reply he's
typing and he says
i'd love to facetime but i can't
i have an android
[Laughter]
my heart dropped is if he just told me
he has a wife
like why would you keep this from me
and i feel like this is something you
should have mentioned up front were you
hiding it
did you think i wasn't gonna find out
i'm sorry but iphone and androids that's
a historical
feud that is like jlo and mariah carey
you know i'm upset i've been bamboozled
as much as i i like this guy i just
can't picture myself in a relationship
without airdrop you know like
can you imagine how am i gonna start
a group chat with you and my family you
see how there's no future here
how which way are we going to raise our
kids like
they'll grow up so confused like if he
goes missing i can't find his location
you know it's just bye-bye
i can i can maybe handle a guy who
you know uh doesn't like dogs a guy who
thinks the earth is flat but that green
bubble
is a deal breaker unfortunately
of course all my friends are getting
married and
their their weddings got postponed
because of the pandemic so now i'm i'm
gonna be a bridesmaid like four
times in september it's just one more
and i get a free boba milk tea
stamp card system and i i hate it
i hate it so much i know a lot of girls
love it but i hate it
like at this point i don't know what's
worse getting asked to be a bridesmaid
or getting selected for jury duty
it's just the same dread same burden
when i open up that envelope
why me you know i wish i could get out
of being a bridesmaid like i can get out
of jury duty
like i wish i could just go to the
wedding and pretend i don't know english
just call up the bride and tell her that
i hate cops like how do i get out of
this
and just like jury duty you're just
forced to interact with people you don't
know
like the bachelorette weekend is a
nightmare and everyone's on their phones
with the instagram going live just
cameras in every direction like what
reality show that i sign up for it's me
the college roommate the cousin the
groom's
sister the the summer camp bff the the
hair stylist
the the college roommate like it's
literally seven strangers
picked to live in a house and have their
lives taped
count me out all right y'all i'm sherry
cola
back to you missy there's no place
like fun can you believe you get to
watch comedy that good right
from your home